Chúng đỏ vọng khoảng không giờ búm nè phút cùng ngày, bán tri huy bộ độ biên phòng tình cảm au tiếp nhận tin báo về sự của xà Lan,
giò ông bỏ phụ xin năm 2019, quay tình ninh bình làm thuyền trường.
Đà Hành trình vẫn truyền và tự án giang giá đà hòn quái khi đến khu vực cạnh cờ biển gặn hào khoảng 8,5 li về hưởng đông.
Phương tiện bất ngờ gặp sống to, giò lớn giận đến chiếm xà Lan, thời điểm gặp nạn trên phương tiện có bún tuần viên.
Ngay sau khi tiếp nhận thông tin, bán tri huy bộ độ biên phòng tình đã chỉ đạo lúc biên phòng gặn hào.
Điều đậm một tổ công tác của bún cạnh bộ trình xí, đồng thời chứng dụng một tổ cá cũng sống lươn tất tóc khẩn trường ra hiệt trường.
Sao sống lò đến vì cũng phát thông báo cho các tổ cá đang hoạt động gần phu vực hỗ trợ tìm kiểm kiểu nạn.
Đến năm giờ, mi hai phút cùng ngày tổ công tác lúc biên phòng gặn hào.
Phối hợp cùng một tổ cá khác đã phát hiện và tiếp cận cứ vốt thành công toàn bộ bún thình viên đang truy ra trên viên.
Đưa lên tổ án toàn.
Hẹn sức khỏe của các thuyên viên đã ổ định.
Gió được hiện thời tiết trên viên có sống tò gió lớn.
Gây nhiều khó khăn cho công tác chủ vớt.
Lực lượng miệp phòng đang tiếp tục phối hợp với các phương tiện tại hiện trường.
Để tính hành phương án, tí huồ, xà Lan, mi chim.